welcome to CBS and walk this morning we
begin with what we think is fantastic
news four crew members rescued from
inside a capsized cargo ship off Georgia
are said to be in good condition this
morning the last of those South Korean
sailors were pulled to safety yesterday
after dramatic rescue operation the
Sailor had been trapped in the bottom of
the ship for almost 40 hours meg Oliver
is in st. Simons Georgia where the
freighter is still lying on its side Meg
what was the man's condition when he got
out Tony good morning he was well enough
to walk off the ship the Coast Guard
tells me he was absolutely elated and
couldn't wait to reunite with his fellow
crew members as for the rescue team it
was an emotional high after completing
such a dramatic rescue rescuers cheered
Monday as the final crewmember emerged
from the golden ray cargo ship where he
had been trapped since early Sunday
morning the man had no food or water
making his situation especially dire
George's high temperatures only added to
the complicated operation I know it's a
lot hotter in that ship than it was for
us on the outside and I'm sure on the
outside it was probably pushing 120 or
more earlier Monday the Coast Guard
rescued three other crew members after
making contact with them by tapping on
the ship's hull a team repelled down the
vessel before drilling holes to reach
the men captain when you first
discovered they were alive what went
through your mind I was elated when we
found out that the tapping was coming
back and that they had it consistently
throughout the night that made all the
difference in the world to the team that
was able to get out there and extract
the more than 650 foot long golden ray
capsized and caught fire after leaving
port was carrying some 4,200 vehicles
that cause is still under investigation
the Coast Guard initially rescued 20
people some by helicopter before the
fire and unstable cargo made it too
risky to continue officials are now
shifting their attention to reopen
the busy shipping channel and assessing
the environmental risk I'm confident
that they will continue to attack those
threats with the same vigor that got to
us finding the four survivors behind me
is one of the busiest shipping channels
for automobiles in the nation for now
the Coast Guard tells me it will remain
closed until they can get the ship out
of here
an official also said that because of
the ship sheer size and location that
will be a monumental task
Anthony great work by the team they'll
Meg thank you